you are looking like mr hollywood
versace oh yeah versace y'all
okay so from
top in the box office with a blockbuster
film are you hoping to be taking home
that number one coveted spot in the
netflix list with this phone
i mean the audience is never wrong
that's what something tom really
impressed upon me so
netflix makes it very easy to see how
how many people are watching it so yeah
it would be it would be nice to kind of
get towards the top of that list for
sure we'll have two number ones at the
same time yeah that'll be that'd be all
right i would i would take that yeah i'd
say so i think many people would what do
you think chris hemsworth's called name
would be if he were in top gun maverick
i mean i guess it would probably be thor
is probably
that's probably uh or mr wonderful i
think is a good one i think mr wonderful
yeah he's he's uh he's a great guy is he
yeah i mean i've interviewed him several
times but what was your take away from
working with him on this film
well i knew he was really funny from you
know the performance that he brings in
thor and
i had seen him in this movie bad times
at the el royale where i thought he
really kind of
gave her performance set that people
were not expecting
uh from him hey joe miss ya
that people are not really expecting and
he's that's he i think he's got
incredible range and he's just a really
dynamic performer
we've heard so many great things that
you've said about this [ __ ] right here
joe
dynamic and great behind the camera what
is it about him that keeps you coming
back more this is the third time that
you all worked together
well i think people at this point this
it's not a secret that that joe is an
incredible filmmaker he's
with a very short resume i think done
some really impressive projects
but for me it goes beyond that because
you have to spend a lot of time with
with this person and for for me really
joe's just a really
pleasant person he's a really nice
person
and that might sound like superfluous
but it really does go a long way as far
as a working relationship goes oh it's
so important because we spend so much i
spend so much time with my crazy uncles
over here how do you guys how do you
guys get along
oh yeah incorrect oh don't even don't
even yeah miles i got to tell you you
were rocking an iconic mustache and top
gun maverick and then in this film you
are rocking what could be an iconic
hairstyle again
what gives with these iconic either
facial hair hairstyles was that your
idea your inspiration i mean it's a
choice i guess people let you know if it
becomes iconic or anything but also in
australia where we filmed it yeah the
mullet has made like a
a roaring comeback it's a really like
kind of
cool
like edgy thing so yeah i don't know
we'll see i'll tell you my wife is not a
fan of either yeah the mullet or the
mustang i knew she wasn't a fan of the
mustache yeah and i gotta be right there
with her on the mullet look i get it for
the character it is the mullet is loud
and proud down south and you know what
it needs to be retired uh there was
growing up in florida there were plenty
of plenty of mullets i don't think
anybody was
saying it was iconic where i grew up
except for billy ray cyrus oh that's
that's the top one for sure finally
what what's up with the teller talks
[Music]
your wife did she have anything else up
her sleeve are you always in the dark
when it comes to these things i'm
definitely in the dark i don't
i kind of find out about stuff through
i don't know other mediums because i
don't have i know i don't have that
stuff but it's
i don't know it's i think she's just
having fun with it so
it'll it'll die away soon and then it'll
be you know something else direct while
the iron's hot that's exactly right i
mean she just oozes glamour
she's beautiful
she's all mine
[Music]